it is May 6 2023 and you're watching the
code report serverless is the biggest
lie in the history of computers why you
always lying when you go serverless
you're still using a server it's just
not yours you'll compute nothing and be
happy Amazon Prime video just dropped a
shocking article explaining how they
saved 90 on their Amazon web services
bill by switching from serverless
microservices to an Old-Fashioned
monolith architecture that's great news
for Amazon because it'll save a ton of
money but bad news for Amazon because it
just lost a great Revenue Source the
article is sending shockwaves through
Tech right now because one of the main
claims of the serverless vision is that
you can scale infrastructure more
efficiently which in theory should cost
less money I really appreciate Amazon's
transparency here because they're one of
the original pioneers of serverless with
Lambda functions and nowadays you have
tons of platforms offering serverless
services like Purcell and netlify which
are actually just using and reselling
AWS Services behind the scenes there's
almost an entire industry of startups
that make AWS easier to use including
open source projects like the serverless
framework and S SST but not everyone is
drinking the Kool-Aid like dhh the
creator of Ruby on Rails and Basecamp
has been advocating for Majestic
monoliths for the last decade and took
his entire company off the cloud after
they spent over three million dollars in
one year now they just run their own
servers a lot of successful startups
like Dropbox end up leaving the cloud
once they get big enough however I
personally use serverless for my
projects and it's an absolute game
changer for getting things done quickly
although I have accidentally created a
few infinitely scaling infinite Loops
that could have potentially cost me an
infinite amount of money but what's the
difference between a microservice and
model with architecture at Prime video
they needed a tool to analyze audio
content or issues like video freeze and
Corruption to implement this tool they
use multiple serverless functions called
Step functions which are basically the
same thing as Lambda to handle different
responsibilities you have an initial
entry point which kicks off another
service to do a file conversion that
converts an audio video stream into
frames that can be used by the detector
you've got multiple detectors using
machine learning to analyze the video
then finally you have another function
to aggregate the result and store them
in a bucket but there's a little bit of
overhead every time you pass data from
one service to another they need to
serialize and deserialize data and
communicate over a network in this case
their service needed to run multiple
times for every second of a video stream
and they quickly hit a bottleneck with
their account limits just trying to
orchestrate the service in addition by
temporarily uploading files to S3 they
were burning through money just
accessing these files in the buckets
they realized that the distributed
architecture was the root cause of these
bottlenecks causing them to make a bold
decision to re-architect to a monolith
instead of running decoupled distributed
Services they took everything and made
it run on a single container all the
components are the same but now that
they run on a single server they can
only scale vertically that means to do
more work they'll need to make each
server bigger unlike the microservice
architecture which could scale
horizontally by creating more service
for each individual component based on
its scaling needs that seems like it
would be a drawback but it eliminated
all kinds of unnecessary communication
and network usage that reduced their
cost by 90 and for a product of this
magnitude that means millions of dollars
saved so I guess the takeaway is that if
you're using microservices you should
probably Cobble them together into a
monolith right now well not so fast in
this case the optimization was pretty
obvious famously back in 2008 Netflix
was based on a monolith architecture and
had a massive failure that motivated
them to break their architecture into
hundreds of different microservices that
can scale independently with fault
tolerance it might be more complex and
expensive but if Netflix goes down for a
few hours it'll cost them way more money
and lost memberships than for small
businesses like me I can easily deploy
my shitty JavaScript code without ever
having to think about infrastructure I
rarely even bust out of the free tier
and when I do it's money well spent
because I have peace of mind knowing
that I'm not going to deploy some bad
code to my monolith that takes down my
entire operation ultimately when it
comes to Cloud architecture there are no
Solutions only trade-offs this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one